rated M for Mature where's scarecrow go
to hell
talk or I'll crush every bone in your
body
okay okay working out of a house know if
you're lying
I'll break the other one the other one
scarecrows got a safe house nearby I'm
going to pay him a visit
how long do we keep her in there until
we get cancer do your worst the boredom
is killing me look who it is I can't say
I'm surprised I think the faster we
flick
something tells me this wasn't part of
the plan
Wow that's made things a little more
interesting
sir it's Batman he's here
were you expecting to find me that
matter I'm afraid I must disappoint you
take a look at the chamber I want you to
know the fears that is coming listen up
that freak
we're walking out of here nice and slow
try anything stupid a floor breakdown
charming but only one of us is getting
out of this cell nothing like a little
natural immunity
Scarecrow said he had a plan that
together we could take you out and
Gotham would be ours over my dead body I
believe that was the idea I told him
that I wasn't interested in his pathetic
human games and when I came to I was
locked up in that room
nature always
will he ever learn
you're coming with me
you only have we need to leave the
master of understatement
as ever
I need to know where those tanks are
coming from I'm tracking several
transport helicopters moving into the
city there are more on the way
activate the Batmobile weapon
Diagnostics
the stream
two GCPD
it's out there thank God
Herman they can resume their
but they were the last don't
I mean the isolation on paper
good to have you here Batman bring her
down to the look
any progress with the fear toxin
analysis it's gonna take a little while
longer
drop by this box here when you're ready
and I'll show you what I've got so far
who taught you to drive
you